Andrew Brent columnist the mmq be the
host of business of sports he works for
the athletic as well had a chance to
talk to Baker Mayfield's agent recently
for his podcast and you know we kind of
unearthed something there which was
interesting Andrew thanks for joining us
on short notice but tell me about this
conversation with Baker's agent and what
we thought was gonna play out perhaps in
their world with the Patriots you always
a pleasure dan I just thought it was
interesting to talk to a guy that's been
around forever
in fact he represented a Heisman Trophy
winner from Oklahoma named Steve Owens
forty-eight years ago and now represents
the one this year so that was
interesting story that Baker didn't go
with one of the big agencies so I'm just
talking to him and talked about his
visits and talked about meeting Baker
and then he just unsolicited talking
about the draft yeah you know we thought
the floor would be the Jets at three but
you know there was a surprise team that
was trying to trade up to two and it'll
surprise you but it was the Patriots and
I'm like oh that's interesting he said
yeah you know they got to number one to
number twos we didn't know if they were
gonna make it happen but obviously at
the point became moot when the Browns
picked Baker and by the way the Browns
picking Baker we learned about it he
learned about it and Baker learned about
just as we did there was no tip-off
would you believe the Patriots were
actually interested if Baker was gonna
be available to you know Dan I do
because first of all there was a visit
josh mcdaniels went down there and it
was reported enough I me but by others
that they wouldn't have taken a visit
unless they got the second number-one
pick and once they did with Brandon
cooks they agreed to a meeting and I'm
just saying the obvious I mean they've
got a 40-year old quarterback they got
no backup and they seem to be enamored
with this kid now whether they'd have
enough ammunition or not to do it who
knows but I think there's something
there yeah what from what I was told and
you might know better
that they to get an interview they had
to tell them that they they were
interested in moving up to get him that
it wasn't that Baker's representatives
were like you're not gonna be up there
he's gonna be taken before that we don't
want to waste time there is that is that
a fair assessment of what happened that
is a fair assessment at when they only
had one number one pick it was written
it was moot to try to schedule an
interview and then they did now whether
that would have led to a blockbuster who
knows kind of fascinating though I mean
it makes his client look better and it
also makes the Browns look better that
hey even Belichick wanted to go up and
get him yeah and I kind of trying to
delve into what is that thing about
Mayfield I mean we look at it yeah he
seems you know as good as those guys who
knows he's a little shorter than the
other three he's got some more moxie the
other three and he just said you know
these teams would call him and say you
know he's got that it whatever that it
is now I know people said about Manziel
too but he just got something with
leadership and got something where he
felt and again it's the agent talking
that not only the Browns but certainly
the Jets probably the Broncos if they
were somehow in position to take him and
of course now we're talking about the
Patriots so these teams seem to have him
above these other three quarterbacks but
also as an agent a former agent have you
ever have you ever had clients that just
say to a team or you've said to a team
on behalf of the client hey you know
what I'm uh I'm not gonna have my guy
interview because he's you're not gonna
be drafting your he's gonna be long gone
I wasn't good enough agent you know my
guys were like please anyone Green Bay
Buffalo or whatever but yeah if you have
that kind of leverage I mean it's the
same thing is not working out at the
combine or not doing pro days because
what do you have to gain you only have
things to lose I get it but it was
fascinating that John Dorsey who I know
from Green Bay just like we were in
Green Bay Ted Thompson we know we never
knew who he really was going to pick and
Dorsey was that way
and no tip-off to the to the mills or
the Baker's at maker Mayfield's at all
and he found out in listening and
watching from Austin Texas as we did and
then you know that was it for Baker
Mayfield no no no noise about the
Patriots are moving into the giant spot
once that happened how often were you
lied to by teams leading up to the dress
Oh
fair amount and remember yeah yeah I
mean if he's there we'll take them that
kind of thing and then it doesn't happen
and then it's the mealy-mouthed listen
Aaron Rodgers my biggest draft story
ever sitting there watching him fall we
found out later from him there were
teams that told him you know if you're
there we'll take you and then all those
teams passed and then we you know the
best player and football fell in our lap
why did they so you're in the war room
they're white why do you think Aaron
Rodgers dropped I don't you know it's
something we talked about Josh Rosen
this year was there something turning
people off about Aaron's his confidence
his kind of California cool is wry sense
of humor all the things we'd like and
the fact it's the position at this is
not like this year's NFL Draft you
didn't have that many teams that were
like we got to have a quarterback
so once Alex Smith went everybody's like
well more need-based and even our
decision like should we dip into our
second-round grades because Aaron was
the only first-round grade left and take
a corner and take a line back or
whatever we needed and our coaches
certainly wanted that because they don't
want a first-round pick that's not going
to help us with the most durable
quarterback in history on a roster but
you know it's trust the board but the
news too far that you'd would take an
errand Roger I got the call from bus
using the agent yeah I didn't talk to
Brett and I told bus what I tell
everyone is listen we trust the board
he's the best player on the board at
some point breasts not gonna be here and
I mean listen we traded quarterbacks all
those years that we have ax and Aaron
Brooks is because we realized I'm never
going to play
but with air and it was obviously
different oh man I would pay to hear
that phone conversation between you two
I don't know who talked to Brett
probably Mike Sherman our coach but but
just it had to be a little bit awkward
as far as Asians callin saying what what
what are you doing now you know why
aren't you getting him you know somebody
who could play a tackle or an offensive
lineman what do you you're drafting a
successor same thing you know you tell
the coaches like coaches are judged and
and PS that coaching staff was fired
that year and we brought in Mike
McCarthy but it's tough you know you
general managers I'm man I was
management your forward focused and
coaches are all about the immediate end
players but would you have taken a
quarterback a few of the Patriots well
you mean expend tons of draft capital to
do this yeah or where they were that you
go up and get one gosh you know I look
at the Eagles I'm sitting in
Philadelphia everyone including me
criticized all the resources they used
to get wins I guess my sense is they
have no plan right there you know they
traded away their plan last year to San
Francisco so my sense is my they were
convicted about this guy yes yeah that
still doesn't make sense that Jimmy
Garoppolo trade Andrew just doesn't with
with what you pay to move up to get
quarterbacks and what you got in return
from San Francisco for Jimmy G just
doesn't make sense I mean they
rationalized it at that point there was
the worst team in the league or with
Cleveland so it's a it's really like a
first-round pick it's 33 or 34 or 35 mm
but in retrospect yeah I mean that guy
could change the power structure of the
NFC West for years and maybe even the
whole division the whole conference one
other thing I seized and I don't know if
you see this but you know the
personality traits or quirks I see Josh
Rose and I see a little bit of Aaron
Rodgers in there as well yeah is that
apt comparison yeah and me personally I
think it's a positive now you too I do
too
you know I
some people say well you know we want
our quarterback to be a football guy and
I'm like really really I mean we don't
want you want to balance to me the most
successful people in life are balanced
and can focus when they need to and he
seems to have kind of this
off-the-charts intelligence and ability
to not take things too seriously totally
like Aaron and I saw video of them
together they show the same agent I like
them and it's just to me it's the other
part of this Dan quickly that's him
Bradford once again wins the business of
football while he's a placeholder
second time in three years no four went
two years ago pretty good now he's a
placeholder and rod Rosen being there
soon enough pretty pretty good he's a
columnist for mmq b.com the athletic
host of businesses sports
he's Andrew Brandt joining us Lamar
Jackson not having an agent how much did
that hurt him I don't think it did much
I mean I think the agent community was
feel threatened they didn't like it
I know they were pushing me to write or
talk about it and I just said let's see
how it turns out
wait other agents were saying you should
be writing about this this is bad yeah
sure sure why aren't you writing about
Lamar Jackson and teens can't reach them
and I called a team and I said if you
probably reaching the large axis no they
call he call he and his mother on a
speakerphone called me two hours after I
called that so I didn't see any of that
and then I'd say let's say it turns out
at that time he was rated maybe second
round yeah no get him the first with a
good team he'll sit behind Flacco
however long and I think he'll be fine
listen you mentioned it I'm a former
agent
I get what agents can do beyond the
contract negotiation and now the CBA pre
negotiates these deals but to be
critical just because he doesn't have an
agent it turned out well what did he
miss by not having an agent set up
workouts or set up training plans or set
up visits that his mother did I'm not
seeing it good stuff Andrew thank you
for joining us
a pleasure Dan that's Andrew Brent
columnist the mmq be for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]